your is facing the worst financial
crisis in a generation
it all started in two thousand seven in
the united states wet over optimistic
banks went bankrupt as a result of bad
lending in the mortgage market
in september two thousand eight the
fourth-largest american investment bank
email has collapsed
the crisis has since passed to the rest
of the world
vicious circle developed
banks stopped lending to each other and
credit dried out
to prevent a complete collapse of the
banking system
european governments came to the rescue
fairfax with urging support on an
unprecedented scale four-point five
trillion dollars
the equivalent of thirty seven percent
of the easing on your g_d_p_ but
committed between two thousand and eight
and two thousand and eleven
the evil
also launched a europe-wide recovery
program
to safeguard job since social protection
levels
and to support economic investment
in this way non-transferable ages
and european savings were protected
the euro broadly maintained its value
and successfully she'll take your isn't
countries
and the worst effects of the economic
crisis
by providing you cos with a stable
playing field for international trade
and investment
but this ethic took at stellar
especially since most of them and they
have to be tolerant
from late two thousand and nine the most
experienced here isn't countries
began to have problems financing that
dance leading to a new development in
the process
this offering ten crisis
with increasing deficits and spiraling
debt
the market's lost confidence in certain
government's ability to pay back what
they have
interest rates for that government bonds
soon became unsustainable
and since many of these bombs were held
by i think european countries on their
backs
they stand into a problem
phrasal
this was especially true for this
country sharing the yoru is that
currency
this loss of confidence let the banks to
be to use their lending to businesses
and private households
in two thousand in nine
shakeel economy suffered its worst
recession since its creation
after a brief recovering
it went into a mild recession again in
early two thousand twelve
as a result
unemployment we've unprecedented levels
in many parts of europe
creating hardship and increasing poverty
levels
stages that means that the your roommate
the crisis once
no
not told you is in countries built-up
excessive deaths
and module countries outside the u_s_
hands
kept that debt under control
being interviewers and
spent the day its members could count on
the summit diocese of the members
because here is an economist also
independent
before prospers
others will benefit
he phone photos
others will suffer
that's why european leaders decided to
step up common action
the key lesson of the crisis
was that europe needed to build a close
and economic union to compliment it's
existing monetary union
and to ensure that the public finances
all sustainable
they easier introduce new stronger rules
to keep a time to check on public debt
and deficits
to make sure countries and spending on
their mailing list
a new fiscal treaty was also signed
defend the strength and confidence
limiting yearly structural deficits
jin not point five percent of the g_d_p_
this crisis clearly shows
it'd get field economies not sustainable
the european commission when i'll make
sure that the limit some debts and
deficits are applied and that national
budgets did not go to grace other
european economies this is the purpose
of a fiscally union
the second european financial
supervision is being stepped up to to
ensure the banks are better capitalized
behave responsibly and are able to lend
money to households and businesses
this paves the way for a bank and union
to make sure the people's deposits are
protected and taxpayers are not forced
to pay for the failure of banks
that firewalls to protect the single
currency being reinforced through the
european stability mechanism a fund that
will help your eyes and countries
there's a temporarily unable to borrow
money on the financial markets
will require support recapitalization of
fractal banks
names will be provided
if countries agreed to reform their
economies
and restore their financial stability
pulled european union will to see the
objectives of the europe twenty-twenty
strategy implementing structural reforms
tab europe's job potential douglas
productivity and competitiveness
this implies targeted investments using
evite and national funds to sustain
cutting-edge research spread innovation
and latest technologies connector
europe's transported energy crystal and
bring high-speed internet to board
europeans
wherever they lived
restoring economic growth is no easy
task
but we are working together to deliver
lasting solutions to the crisis
we need found public finances across
europe and solidarity mechanisms for
crisis situations fiscal union
we need stronger supervision of the
financial markets at banking
we needed depicted canot making him with
competent restaurant
to bruce greatest and competitiveness
the european union is the people's
project blanketing democracy and
accountable to voters
it must emerge from this crisis stronger
and more united than ever bertrand
political union with a reinforced
european parliament prospers hand breaks
five hundred million citizens and a
strong plant in the world